hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at [ __ ] boys
- the seagull the five nights at [ __ ]
boys one if you don't know simple
mathematics and I'm here joined again
once again by my best friend in the
world unnamed cinnamon whisky even
though the names right there for
everybody to see its unnamed and my
friend and it's gonna be joining me on
this adventure but remember everybody
watching if you are easily offended by
anything that happens in this type of
game where the name says [ __ ] boys in it
then you might want to go away we don't
want your kind around here and I've got
my clever little pink shot glass this
time not so much skull of death but pink
shot glass of fun and I've got a rainbow
of colors over there to join me on my
adventure so it's gonna be a lot like
last time wow it looks like there's a
lot more I think this actually might be
a double shot glass but I'm not sure I'm
gonna try to go easy if it seems like a
little bit more than it was before we're
looking at it right now it might be but
same rules apply I'm gonna take a shot
at the beginning of every episode then
play through it as best I can all in one
sitting but I heard this one might be a
little longer and also I missed some
content in the last game that people
yelled at me about but I'm not gonna go
back because I don't feel like drinking
again just to do that one episode so
either way cheers everybody
congratulations on a great five nights -
[ __ ] boys one not that you really had
anything to do with making it but you
sat through it and watch me plate so
that means a lot to me and here's to
another great game then we're gonna have
lots of fun together with thanks
everybody
oh this is gonna be a good day oh it's
gonna be a good day oh warning what
warning is that the warning that I just
said certain visual effects used in this
game may be harmful to those who suffer
from epilepsy so that's another warning
that you guys need to be mindful of
there's gonna be bright flashing colors
would you like to login no absolutely
not screw you okay so as I went with
normal mode and last one I'm gonna do
the same one in this one because frankly
I don't even know how the hell I would
be able to do anything whoo please yes
please disable the copyrighted songs
I'll add in my own stuff later if it
needs a little more punch but for right
now I don't need any of that trouble
grand reopening Freddy & Co want out a
night of debauchery and to do so
[ __ ] on all the cameras please enlist
thunk oh hello
oh man it's me toy Freddy happy birthday
I don't think that's how that goes
well medium pizza was found okay then so
this is already slightly different no
I'm not ready for that but also it's
very much the same oh here come Oh
streamers okay so instead of doing it
like it was before I'm facing streamers
this time oh it's already seems familiar
oh it's gonna be so much fun
I'm already eager to play it again not
just for the sake of me drinking a whole
lot why is this guy not dead
Jesus why did that guy take so much
damage okay either way it's gonna be
this is gonna be a bit of a bear at
least hopefully I'm not gonna die right
off the bat because I got a medium beats
here okay so what I need to do is I need
to first find out what's in here now the
medium pizza then I need to go okay well
not yet I need more liquor in me before
I equivalently turn into a badass ooh I
forgot I was totally in the mindset of
being the other type of game but I
forgot that it was the same over here
oh really toy Freddy you didn't regular
Freddy have another argument with this
right before old about to go in the
bathroom a what a son of a [ __ ] gonna
make me waste another pizza on this side
of which oh man I'm so ready because
I've heard that this game is a lot more
interesting than the last one oh this is
badly
[Music]
thank you Jesus
ah man I did not read the power I got to
be mindful of that or I'm gonna find
myself very dead very soon okay spare
parts room is over here okay this looks
creepy and decrepit play cake sure send
Kate to child Pressy to quit okay sound
like fun is it involved in my 92 pottery
that lets go I didn't do anything
play Foxy's Stepan Cove you mean is
gherkin cove up down the keys to guide
the foxy through the obstacle course
game becomes faster as you go okay up
and down these games work appropriately
got 96 points yeah I was [ __ ] stupid
our play puppet love o my cities the
purple guys shown your tickle fingers
okay
let me touch your but let me you can't
how about how about please what if I say
please please it's perfect pleasure time
I don't think that was the name of the
game
nah fine screw you then we're girls I
won't there's probably some secret
involved with those games but no I had
no idea okay
so [ __ ]
I'm a runaway oh that never fails okay
oh my god I thought I was gonna die like
right off the bat in this stupid game
now that it's stupid it's just you know
you know what I mean
Ivan even found balloon boy yet her hand
I think I saw in the main area there was
like a oh there's a party hat here
ah here we go oh no oh no this is bad
okay I [ __ ] up oh shut up cranky
you're not even cranky you're the
original Donkey Kong put on cranky face
if that made any sense at all
alright so that was to be expected I
haven't drunk nearly enough to be good
at this game why would I have any skill
yet alright so what I need to do is a
shuttle running away so what I need to
do is I need to go back to the main area
and try to find a way to get some of my
bros cuz if I have my Bros with me then
I'm gonna be able to do whatever I need
to do to be able to beat this game I'm
gonna be one streamer down telling me to
get the dragon dildo see once again I
didn't look up anything about this game
so I don't know there's gonna be some
secret that I'm gonna miss and
everyone's gonna be so mad at me about
this isn't what I thought it was gonna
be ah come on oh god damn it I find
where the roads buy some pizzas is this
what I need
apparently I thought I thought I
stumbled upon something like really
cuz everyone was like getting on my case
about not getting the dragon dildo in
the last one I like
I understand I don't know why anyone
want a dildo of a dragon but hey there
you go why not it's the thing god damn
it okay no used to be for good children
but now dragon dildo I hope it is oh I
can't have it I find then what's over
here whoa
mangle don't look too good I'm gonna go
say hi nice [ __ ] I forgot and mango
mango leg I'm not your child my god like
a dragon dildo
so now I gotta find an esoteric sex toy
okay who's Michael Jackson oh I got you
yeah [ __ ] oh god I'm not ready for this
oh come on
[Laughter]
haha god damnit gonna send me all the
way back to the beginning god dammit or
the other room over there [ __ ]
alright so all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
try to explore down here and not die cuz
dying is what I seem to be very good at
well what am I supposed to do where am I
supposed to find my bruise god damn it
all the rules have changed it was like a
balloon boy on the wall but I think that
was a Balloon Boy paper mache thingy
well I guess I just got a farm up like
gasps well let me get this thing again I
use my magic fingers to tickle my way to
the vending machine if you know what I
mean there we go thank you know what I
needed
[ __ ] I'm gonna go just bear with me
everybody I wonder what sort of hidden
game references they're gonna have in
the game near this time because far too
drunk to figure out anything that was
going on before so now I just got to
figure it out on my own all right so I
need pizzas to be able to farm I don't
think I have any skills yet but I don't
think that this thing comes with skills
does it oh cool I can buy boosts that
means if I have so many tokens I'm
actually gonna be able to do something
with it
okay so somehow I need to find an
esoteric sex toy for foxy but I think
that also means that I'm gonna pay
[Music]
okay I was wondering when that was gonna
stop how is that fair
I've been going Freddie just pop out
indeed much appreciated without my
permission
damn it what a bunch of baloney go I
have to just like save at random in URLs
just in case that happens because holy
[ __ ] god dammit what a Saba [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah it looks like I learned a skill
I'd guys do this again I gotta use my
magic fingers everybody gotta use my for
god damn it this is such a piece of [ __ ]
I mean place why why this has got to be
such a ding dong er dick bag all right
[ __ ] whatever this this this is not cool
not cool bruh not cool you better not
I've got an IE from a pic well I guess
I'll save it every single opportunity I
have and then I guess I'm just gonna
form these streamers cuz I don't know
where else to find anyone else I mean
I'm guessing that I got a traverse the
area to be able to get the things that I
need to get and find the guys that I
need to find the same time it's like
well so I do but says this farm up mr.
Freddie man here hurts real bad but you
ain't gonna do nothing to me
oh ok there's some getting more critical
it's than last time I don't know I don't
know if the level cap still gonna be 20
and somebody pointed out like some
people pointed out a lot of things while
I was already done with the game and
finished recording and there was no
input that you could have had but people
are still like no you need to do this
thing go back and do it I'm like it it's
done didn't you understand the rules of
the game I played it all in one
no breaks oh come on I wonder if that
golden Freddy thing is like one in a
thousand chance and I just so happen to
be screwed over by it because I'm such
an ass bag
oh no it's making me paranoid now okay
so as far as my understanding goes
probably what I need to do is I need to
be able to find my guys once I find my
guys I'll be able to build up my team
but I need to get them as soon as
possible
but I also need to get strong enough to
be able to find them whole lot of
problems it's a whole lot of project too
many problems
okay that's what that's what Wade was
telling me when I first started playing
this game he was like be prepared to
farm oh it's like ok but da man I didn't
know why are there three cameras in this
one room alone alright so what else can
I do I guess I could go talk to foxy but
at the same time that might open me up
to punishment that I don't want to
experience okay so if I can go down into
the other rooms and try to find maybe
there's okay what's this this looks bad
I shouldn't be here the dam it's way too
high and this one screw that kid ain't
happy here screw you there's gotta be
like something in the part room over
here because otherwise this is a big
empty room and I refuse to believe it
there's gotta be something here there's
got to be something whoa it was a metal
streamer and just ran away and I
couldn't do no damage to it was i voting
if it's dick who is a [ __ ] if it okay
let me try this again
maybe I wasn't using the right controls
I was using the arrows and said WASD
maybe oh okay oh so that one did work
okay I got okay I got I got okay I'm
gonna do this again watch watch watch
watch watch water gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme yo goo goo goo
goo gimme gimme gimme
yes okay I got this I
now I was just doing it too late before
okay I'm ready I'm ready
come on bring it on okay okay all right
hold up
Oh down down up
okay I gotta be like I gotta like spam
it wow there's really fun I'm having
such a great time I can't believe how
much fun I'm having
Wow this fine I don't know what that
one's for me why I'm gonna have to like
get a walkthrough for this stupid [ __ ]
maybe there's another thing where I just
got it like spam as much as possible
okay
BRB I'm gonna I'm gonna spam the hell
out of this what what did I did I don't
know if I actually did something or if
it was all just [ __ ] oh oh we said
yes okay cool
what did I win I won nothing goes a big
waste of time son of a [ __ ] okay so
somehow I got to get rid of this guy so
I can get to Balloon Boy so I'm pretty
sure that's why I'm here so that's my
next objective I'm gonna get enough
experience such that I can fight that
thing and then be able to move on with
my life and get something from Balloon
Boy because probably I can by an
esoteric sex toy from Balloon Boy cuz
that's a thing I don't even know if
balloon boys a thing in this game but
either way it's the only option I have
at the moment so it's what I'm gonna do
okay bye okay okay I could buy cake
donuts soda I don't know what any of
this is or four so I guess I'll just
keep buying pizzas then farm up so oh I
have a skill don't I didn't I get a
skill for Toy Fair okay top hat slash
level one toy Freddy removes his top hat
and use it as a [ __ ] sward seriously
okay cool
does that mean that I need to buy uh I
probably need to buy soda because I need
to you see skills more because everyone
everyone is yelling at me like you need
to use backup bash and I'm like we've
been through this I am not playing the
game anymore is like no use backup back
you dumbass and like I would if I knew
that now but you don't seem to
understand how time works ok beta that's
besides the point I'm getting angry
overnight Oh another shot I want another
shot real badly but I gotta wait until
the next episode because I know that
this game might actually be longer than
the last one so I want to make sure that
I paced myself out pretty well
so they don't get myself in trouble
which is something that I definitely
good do if I'm not careful oh tech oh
that's the UH that's for the special
ability that I get or what I got in the
last game when I when I beat on the feet
on the other dudes my toy versions but
now that I am the toy versions like I
said kind of changes things
I mean I'll probably have to face my not
toy versions but that's for another day
okay I don't know if I'm good enough to
beat that hallway thing but I'm gonna
try because they get items and I get a
skill okay
skill go oh wow that did a lot of damage
a boy what is the UPS my friend knows
would you like to purchase my wares
there is there's this slogan okay so now
let's see I can probably yeah okay so so
those are all the things I will get
mangle I'll get toy chica toy Bonnie and
Freddy's so for now I'm just gonna buy
Freddy's crap and then buy some
equipment
what do you communist Balloon Boy stop
being so cheerful about things okay
this by this by this like this okay cool
cool cool alright so now that I got this
I can just put them all on with
optimized cool done so now it should be
much more stronger than I was before and
hopefully I'll be able to do the things
that I need to do be able to get this
good hopefully this is all big hopefully
I don't know if it's for certain but
it's hopefully oh oh also do you have an
esoteric sex toy I probably don't even
need to go talk to mangle first now Oh
like no damage at all I'm so badass now
you don't even understand oh good I
haven't things except for what I miss
like a [ __ ]
and everyone laughs at me because I'm so
stupid I've asked besides the point
I'm saving just in case golden Freddy
decides the rear is stupid head again
okay Oh Oh God please please let this
work
damn it does way too close if I would've
been [ __ ] over like that oh [ __ ] okay
oh it's him again so what do I do about
that I don't do anything
hmm all it does is guard what happens if
I guard ah what up baby okay that's got
to be some sort of a secret that not
many people are gonna tell me or
everyone's gonna tell me in the comments
below and I'm never gonna know because I
play this all-in-one all-in-one
what are you got for me boy what do you
got for me boy Oh balloons in here's my
dog no you don't this confuzzled
so mmm there's got to be something else
here was there where was there another
uh let me go back in the bathroom here
for there's something else here that a
boys bathroom
bad news okay I forgot about that it's
gotta be like something else that I
don't know about it can't be like it
can't be it can't be it can't be oh this
is weird
it's really weird like I'm not sure what
I'm supposed to be doing now there's no
clear direction now I can get my
teammates on board because before I was
at least introduced to like all of them
no I wasn't because she it was in the
kitchen but that could have been guests
so like where are they now is there some
area that I'm forgetting about or
something it's gotta be something like
I'm at a loss I might need to pull up a
walk through the for this because I
don't want to make people angry and miss
things but at the same time I don't want
to spoil anything I kinda like the fact
that in the last game I was just kind of
on my own by myself doing everything by
myself and not needing anybody's help
I'm still doing things wrong but
admittedly I did pretty good for being
on my own time too I guess
yeah whatever I won't do my own too much
okay so there's got to be something else
here
good fun maybe I can go crawling in the
vents because if I go crawl on the mats
there might be someone there I would be
able to do what I needed to do it's all
just a guess at this point maybe so
sorry I keep adjusting my uh my mic
because it's hard to hear me because the
music is very loud okay so there was
nothing in here correct this is a level
one area but there were the three
machines but I didn't seem to be able to
find out what they did so I'm gonna go
ahead and say no the only other place
that I haven't explored yet is the the
vents here so if I come on oh so uh why
[Music]
I need to get good I got that I get it
I'm not good I understand okay good
thank you that's even worse than it was
before
okay all right sorry okay god dammit
what am I supposed to do okay what about
the poster on the wall is that anything
is that like a thing that I need to
check out cuz I gotta remember this like
secrets to this game there's little itty
bitty nooks and crannies that I need to
go through actually maybe that vending
machine had an esoteric sex toy I didn't
look at now I'm Han let me look again
let me look let me look let me look look
look I mean there's a lot of like flavor
stuff in this game that I don't know
about a lot of stuff that I missed in
lesson two apparently in the last one if
you played he began to add a higher
difficulty level and then imported
you're saved from like xxx mode and last
one into this one it would give you a
special scene but I don't have the
energy to do that I can't do that oh I
see okay so these are unique to the
vending machine and the other ones are
not okay all right gotcha
why would you buy why would you buy a
large pizza that costs three times as
much but only it feels double as a
medium doesn't make any sense at all now
this really makes any sense so my only
guess is that there's got to be
something else in Foxy's area that might
have something to do oh oh maybe I can
just be blue boy here maybe that's got
to be you know skills go go my favorite
top hat go haha
there we go okay so I just got to keep
doing that well gold Freddie's laughing
off wow that really hurt oh my god
I'm not oh this is gonna kill me this is
gonna kill me oh [ __ ] how can I beat
that it's only like a little too here
isn't it isn't a level tuning
damn it cuz these things are hard so
like one of these top hats that maybe is
gonna be oh [ __ ] you get away from me I
don't know what that metal one does why
does something important that everyone's
gonna be yelling to me at about again
but I don't know how am I supposed to
know I know I can't beat one of the
cameras not yet
Wow that guy didn't even attack me I
just like blasted through the both of
them okay gotta be something I know I
know it's staring me right in the face
but I I don't know I mean maybe I just
got to be one of the cameras so if
they're for naughty adults that means
there might be an esoteric sex om can I
open it up for Monsieur foxy okay okay
so what I'm going to do again is I'm
gonna go back into the other rooms try
to find a level two area and then maybe
just maybe I'll be able to do something
here but right now I'm like at a total
loss because this doesn't make any sense
okay so there's got to be something in
here gotta be something in here ah oh I
didn't know we were gonna need smooth
jazz fighting music here oh bam bam bam
done thank you okay barely rewarding for
those fights but good enough I'm at
least at the point where I can kill them
comfortably okay so if there's something
on the wall here
no you really have nothing to say about
those things on the walls really god
damn it what a son of a [ __ ] okay at
least he's dead god there's got to be
something else I found another skill but
Jesus's gotta be something else here
can't just ball be a mystery there's a
bad Hut top hat there but I bet that
one's gonna kick my ass too here we go
get my ass kicked I didn't even get to
the point oh [ __ ] me come on there we go
Jesus you gotta make me use all my
freakin items I guess I could have used
the pizza slicer for that but screw it
screw it I'm gonna waste all my stuff
because I'm probably gonna die anyway
come on what is that somehow slides are
in his top hat into the it doesn't make
sense at all what are you talking about
whoa damn 900 damn it holy hell that's
nice come on at least it doesn't do like
it does like less and less damage each
time okay
this isn't gonna do me very much because
he's gonna do just yep he did just as
much damage as he first that time okay I
can beat this guy shut up Frankie okay
so so that that attack only does the
most damage on the first shot and then
from there it's merely okay all right so
either way you slice this yeah come on
you bastard you [ __ ] bastard okay there
we go come on I'm gonna beat you into
the ground then I'm gonna end this
episode because begin to kind of been
running long okay so the first attack
does a lot of damage no it does not it
does a wide variety of damage okay [ __ ]
I'm not gonna are I [ __ ] I'm
okay all right I can't beat I'm gonna
find out what to do in the next episode
be the way I'm at a lot for this one so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will figure this out in the next one
I mean of course I'm not nearly at my
optimal skill here I'm not drunk yet but
I will be drunk very soon so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the annotation for more videos I've done
check out the entirety of five nights of
fuckboys one in the description below
and as always I will see you
[Music]